the state of new york is exaggerating
covid hospitalizations by as much as 50
now before you censor me
i know you in big tech are itching to
censor me for saying that i promise you
this is not merely my opinion okay not
just little old me this is the opinion
of the liberal democrat governor of new
york kathy hokel who on monday admitted
that she has seen firsthand how the
numbers are being significantly over
counted here's what she said someone's
in a car accident they go to the
emergency room they test positive for
kovid while they're there they're not
there being treated for covet now
someone's condition can worsen while
they're in the hospital i'm not saying
that won't happen but i've just been
doing a random call around to some of
the hospital leaders that i touch base
with and i'm seeing numbers from 20 to
sometimes 50 percent that's the governor
of new york
talking to a new york
news outlet
so the democrat governor of new york is
saying the sort of thing that we have
been saying for two
years now
the only difference is that when we said
it we were called conspiracy theorists
and threats to the public health and
murderers when she says it it's treated
as scientific gospel truth so
instead of playing catch-up like
conservatives always do the logical
question to ask right now is this
what are they lying to us about today
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday is from the
frogprince89 who says we need to start
using the term fake science like trump
used fake news whenever the left changes
the science like
like this year's fashion trend that's a
great
point sometimes we conservatives we
overthink things we think oh what's
going to be the what's going to be the
most clever
subtle way no just use fake news first
of all the fake news is a term that the
left used to criticize conservative
outlets
including and especially the daily wire
and then trump appropriated the term and
used it and said are you talking about
the daily wire and the conservative
outlets they're not fake news cnn is
fake news msnbc is fake news so yeah why
don't we just use that that's a great
point it's so blunt it's so simple
everyone knows what we're talking about
dr fauci joe biden the liberal
establishment they're peddling fake
science so simple here's something
that's pretty simple how about you make
your mortgage work for you and you get a
better rate that's why you should
probably check out american financing as
we begin a new year it is a good time to
sharpen your financial game plan
consider your budget your goals and
think about the things you can do today
to come out ahead such as
refinancing your mortgage
if it's not on your to-do list it should
be i know just the people who can help
american financing this is a
family-owned mortgage lender that is
known for its customized home loan
solutions its no pressure approach to
lending is
terrific it's super easy they've got
lower rates
shorter terms even debt consolidation
they do whatever it takes to set you up
for financial success helping you save
up to a thousand dollars a month and
tens of thousands long term get your
free mortgage review today be sure to
ask about skipping two mortgage payments
two mortgage payments it's amazing it's
possible when you call
800-685-5696 that's
8685-5696 or
if you are more digitally inclined you
can go to
americanfinancing.net nmls 182 334 nmls
consumeraccess.org
we talked on the show yesterday about
how
the determining factor for censorship is
not
what is said
but who says it
so when i say something about how
hospitalizations are being exaggerated
that's fake news that's misinformation
that's dangerous it's a threat to the
public health we got to censor the guy
but then when the democrat governor of
new york says exactly the same thing
that's good that's fine because she
she's a democrat she's a prominent
democrat and she's not a mean old
conservative
podcaster there's a complicating factor
here
and this complicating factor is
exemplified by dr robert malone dr
robert malone is one of the people who
invented mrna vaccine technology he was
an early pioneer on that technology
and even people who disagree with him
give him a lot of credit for developing
the technology that is now powering most
of the vaccines we see around us for the
coronavirus so robert malone has gone
out and criticized a lot of the public
health response to
covet
notably he's criticized dr fauci whom he
says has no integrity and lies all the
time
are cotton and surgical masks effective
at preventing the spread of omicron
yeah
when the cdc says they are effective in
fact they are
dr malone that's a lie is that not true
yes it's a i mean it's tony uh uh what
can i say tony has no integrity he lies
all the time and i've me and my peers
have have been watching this for decades
we just shrug our shoulders and shake
our heads and say it's fouchy
this is not just some disgruntled
scientist or
public health official uh complaining
about dr fauci this has been said widely
for decades since the aids epidemic that
dr fauci is a bureaucrat he's not a
great scientist he's a bureaucrat the
good scientists stay in the lab the
bureaucrats push paper like dr fauci
that all he really cares about is being
on tv that he jumps the gun that he is
incompetent that he mishandles things i
mean this has gone back decades and
decades
dr malone has been censored he's been
kicked off of twitter
an episode that he did with joe rogan is
being suppressed by big tech
so what this shows you is it's not it's
not just about what is said
because the liberal establishments
totally changed their tune on kovid on
the efficacy of vaccines on the efficacy
of masks it's not just about what is
said and it's not even just about who is
saying it
in the sense that it's not just about
the credentials often what i would hear
when i would
push back against big tech censorship in
the last couple of years is i would hear
well michael you're making a point that
might turn out to be true but you're not
a credentialed scientist
you don't have a degree from some
medical school or some epidemiology
program you don't work at the nih so
even if you're saying the same thing as
as someone else you don't have the right
to say because you don't have the
credential but there's nobody more
credentialed than dr robert malone
the guy's got very impressive
scientific degrees he was a fellow at
harvard he
helped to develop the vaccine technology
that is at issue right now
but what's the problem the problem is
he's on the wrong side
so it's not just what he's saying
it's not just who he is and his
credentials
it's a much more basic political
question who are his friends who are his
enemies
who are his allies what side is he on
he's he is right now
not on the side of biden fauci the nih
the corporations the liberal
establishment he's not on their side
so they're going to shut him up and it
doesn't matter how many degrees he's got
doesn't matter how central his role was
to the development of these vaccines
he's out
he's out
so how do we fight back against this one
gop representative is
is showing us how to do it
representative troy niels
has just submitted
a joe rogan episode with dr robert
malone into the congressional record so
so this episode you know these rogan
shows go on forever and and this episode
is being suppressed on big tech so this
congressman comes out and he says okay
i'm going to read it verbatim into the
congressional record can't censor that
dorsey or whoever the new guy is agrawal
can't censor that mark zuckerberg
he says quote today i submitted the
transcript from the joe rogan experience
podcast episode 1757
to dr uh with dr robert malone into the
congressional record big tech wants to
restrict your access to this information
but they cannot censor the congressional
record for now for now but
what we're seeing here is really great
it's a reassertion of political rights
and it's kind of weird for the for the
conservatives and for the right in
america because for decades we were told
by the right and by conservatives
government bad everything government
does is bad corporations good everything
corporations do is good
but now we're in a situation where we
need to turn to the government to
protect us against corporations because
the corporations specifically big tech
are controlling all the speech in our
government in our in our society and in
self-government speech is politics and
politics is speech so if they control
the speech they control the whole damn
political system
so now we're in this strange position
where we're saying no help us big
government hey big government help us
against
big
tech and big corporations
republicans are partially responsible
for giving corporations all this power
we are we are and i'm not saying you and
me specifically we're you know
i'm a little uh a little young i was i
wasn't around during a lot of the
battles of the 80s and the 90s okay i
was but a glint in my father's eye still
republicans had this idea that as long
as you deregulated everything you gave
all this power to corporations you'd be
in a better position and that's not
always true
circumstances and threats change in
politics
sometimes the threat is from big
government
sometimes the threat is from big media
sometimes the threat is from big
bureaucracy sometimes the threat is from
big corporation sometimes the the
threats change okay and a conservative
movement that does nothing but repeat
brainlessly the same platitudes from
1982 is not going to be very effective
you need to respond to the threats we've
got now and right now what that means is
growing our political power asserting
our political power using the state
not to put too fine a point on it
to
rein in corporations that are selling
our country and our rights and our way
of life down the river speaking of the
us congress and what people are allowed
to say
i just read
the most disgusting article
i think i have ever read in the
associated press
this is really really gross
ap news headline ashley babbitt a martyr
her past tells a more complex story
ashley babbitt is the military veteran
who was shot
at the capitol the january 6th
insurrection
the worst attack ever worse than pearl
harbor were you know you remember that
where
conservatives were killing cops none of
that happened the only person who got
killed that day in political violence
was this lady ashley babbitt because of
some trigger-happy cop at the capitol
and the ap
comes out and says yeah
yeah you think she shouldn't have been
shot i don't know she wasn't a great
lady and what's the the evidence oh the
evidence was
she got in a fight with her husband's
ex-wife
seriously that's the they say you know
ashley babbitt she's seen you everyone's
saying she's like a good
u.s military veteran but actually she
got into a big fight with her boy or
with her husband's ex-wife so they dig
up all this dirt about her personal life
and her romantic life and they say yeah
because of that
she's bad she deserved to be shot by a
cop that's the insinuation they don't
say it explicitly but that is
the insinuation
of
course the left would never do
what they are doing to ashley babbitt to
someone like
george floyd
george floyd complete degenerate career
criminal regardless of what you think
about how he was killed if it was
justified if it was murder as the
jury found
but i don't think it's very convincing
regardless of what you think about this
this guy was a thug career criminal who
never reformed his life who was
committing a crime as he was killed who
was resisting arrest who was
had a lethal dose of fentanyl in his
system
he
was
putting himself in a position
where things were probably not going to
turn out very well for him if not that
day then into the future
and if you said that if you mention that
he he
robbed a woman at gunpoint a woman who
may have been pregnant there was some
question as to whether or not she was
pregnant but very well may have been
if you bring that up you're a racist
you're terrible you're victim blaming
you're doing all sorts of awful things
michael brown
like remember michael brown he was the
young man in ferguson missouri he robbed
a store and then attacked a cop and
grabbed the cop's gun and the gun
discharged and then michael brown was
killed in the altercation you remember
that if you mention any of that if you
mention the fact that michael brown
started it and was grabbing the cop's
gun you're a racist terrible victim
blaming
dante wright dante wright this is this
one's slightly more controversial dante
wright young man
career criminal rap sheet a mile long
gets pulled over in a traffic stop the
the cop
who has been found guilty of
manslaughter is going to jail
she
meant to tase him she actually shot him
with a gun with a real gun with bullets
and
if you mention well dante wright you
know he was resisting arrest well he did
have a rap sheet a mile long well if he
just kind of gone gone quietly if he had
just
done what he was supposed to do
he wouldn't be dead if you say that
you're a vicious evil terrible monster
racist whatever
but of course when it's conservatives
yes she deserves she deserved the bullet
because she got in a fight with her
husband's ex-wife
she deserved it of course why are they
doing this now why is the associated
press
going after ashley babbitt
almost exactly a year after she was
killed oh right that's why
right because tomorrow
january 6th is the most important feast
day
in the
liberal calendar this is a sacred sacred
day it actually is a sacred day tomorrow
by the way because tomorrow january 6th
for christians is the feast of the
epiphany this is the feast of christ
presented to specifically to the three
magi and this has been celebrated for a
very long time so one way to really get
the libs upset is if you say oh i love
january 6th i can't wait to celebrate
january 6th january 6th is such a great
day oh yes i'm planning my festivities i
love it i think it's so wonderful and
then you explain to them that it's the
epiphany maybe you're celebrating other
things i don't know but certainly you
could be celebrating the epiphany
the left has a feast day tomorrow too
and they need to rewrite the story
before the feast day their story
of what happened on january 6th was fake
it was made up
the officer brian siknik was attacked
with a with a fire hydrant and he was
killed nope didn't happen it was an
insurrect an armed insurrection nope it
wasn't none of the people are being
charged with insurrection none of them
were armed it was they almost took over
the country nope they almost raped aoc
aoc wasn't even in the building they uh
they nearly nope they didn't they you
know what they did
they danced around the capitol with a
horn hat on and they took nancy pelosi's
lectern not defending it you shouldn't
take people's lecterns
wasn't the worst insurrection ever
wasn't the worst insurrection of that
year
actually not even close to blm so they
need to rewrite the history and they're
going to go into overdrive to do it and
the reason they're doing that is they
recognize that
sometimes you hear this phrase politics
is downstream of culture okay whatever
that phrase is worth culture is
downstream of religion
all human conflict is theological all of
politics ultimately comes down to
religion whether you want to admit it or
not all of our political debates
raise moral questions those moral
questions have a religious foundation
our understanding of who we are as
individuals as a community as a nation
comes down to religious questions what
does it mean to be a man what are our
obligations to our neighbors and
ultimately to our god and the left knows
this and so the left is crafting the
religion the feast days the liturgical
calendar the secular saints st george
floyd is one of the most important
saints in the american secular religion
i don't think he's worthy of admiration
normal people don't think he's worthy of
admiration
but
that is what the the left requires
because it serves their political agenda
and so they're going to go into
overdrive on january 6th
and there's probably very little that
that you can do about it
other than
the only way we're going to fight this
is not just by saying this is false this
is fake this is not true the only way
we're going to fight this overwhelming
force of religion
is by having our own religion
and this is why i i jokingly sort of
bring up the fact that there is an
actual feast tomorrow called the feast
of the epiphany you should celebrate it
you should have your own religion you
should have you should
if you want to fight back against the
religion of leftism it's not going to be
enough to just poke holes in it you're
going to need your own form of worship i
would recommend the religion that formed
our country and our civilization and the
whole world if you ask me christianity
i would recommend that because nature
pours a vacuum and in the vacuum of
belief that that exists in america kooky
ideas are going to fill it what's what's
the old line when you don't believe in
any i think it was from chesterton
when you don't believe in anything you
believe in everything
because you just become extremely
superstitious and gullible speaking of
crime
there's a new program in new york
new
public health program in new york
you know there's a big drug problem
leading killer of young americans
had over 100 000 americans die of drug
overdoses i think last year
well this pilot program
is going to install
vending machines to give druggies
needles
and
other drugs that will make it easier for
them to do drugs without killing
themselves by overdosing
they're calling these public health
vending machines
i don't think giving syringes
to heroin addicts
necessarily promotes the public health
you it's sort of the opposite of health
you would think
this is being pushed by the fund for
public health in new york
they opened a request for these
stalls in december
and they're going to offer the
overdose drugs and the syringes and
quote other harm reduction and wellness
supplies
do you think this is compassionate
i
i don't think this is compassionate
i don't think it's compassionate to
create incentives for druggies to do
more drugs now their argument is well at
least they're not using dirty syringes
yeah but they're still shooting up a
bunch of heroin and other drugs
they're making the problem worse yes
well but it's
look if they're gonna do it and look
they have the right they have the right
to do what they want with their bodies
and so that's what i think that's what a
lot of these people believe
a lot of them are on the legalization
train they think oh well just legalize
it regulate it people have a right to do
drugs you don't have any right to tell
them they can't do drugs and so we'll
just make it a little bit safer it's a
safety issue
the war on drugs failed
they say you ever hear that i hear this
all the time the war on drugs was a
failure michael are you you're defending
the war on drugs
yes
yeah i'm definitely defending the war on
drugs the war on drugs totally worked
okay from the 1970s to the 1990s during
the height of the war on drugs use of
illegal drugs in the united states
dropped precipitously and then we
stopped really enforcing the war on
drugs and guess what happened
the use of illegal drugs skyrocketed and
now we're in the worst opioid crisis
ever and we're in
more broadly one of the worst drug
crises ever and we we've now got
a hundred thousand americans a year
killing themselves on this stuff so yeah
the drug the war on drugs did work
the the pro-drug conservatives are
shockingly gullible
they know
that the liberal media lie to them about
basically everything they know
that the activists and the
bureaucrats and the politicians lie to
them about almost everything
and yet they think they're telling the
truth about the war on drugs the war on
drugs was great
it was awesome the reason that people
oppose it has very little to do with the
science because according to the signs
the war on drugs worked it has to do
with this ideology this obsession with
individualism and autonomy this
obsession this idea it's not a
scientific idea this is a philosophical
idea that you have the right to shoot
yourself up with poison
and you don't you don't
and this crazy philosophical idea that
it makes you more free to be able to
shoot up yourself with poison it doesn't
make you free it makes you a slave drug
addicts are not free they're the least
free people in the world they are slaves
to their most base passions and desires
and if you could talk to any of them
when they're in their right mind 100 out
of 100 of them will tell you they don't
want to do drugs because it makes them
miserable
pretty dubious science there in new york
speaking of new york
and dubious science
there's a great piece in the new york
times i know i know
never say i'm not fair
i know i know a chilly day in hell to
say there's a great piece in the new
york times
it's a piece about
genetic testing for pregnant women
you know if you've ever had a kid if
you've ever gone through any kind of
for fertility programs or if you just
had a kid yourself or if you just read
about it you know that when women are
pregnant
there are these genetic tests
and you get them early on and they tell
you oh yes your kid is very likely to
have down syndrome or your kid is very
likely to have this disease or this
disorder or this thing they'll give you
a whole litany
and the purpose of these tests
maybe is to help you prepare for life
with
a child who has these challenges
but really what the tests are for is to
impel you to
abort your baby that's what it's really
about and the doctors will tell you this
you say i asked a doctor once i said
hold on why do you want to do all these
tests they say well just you know to
figure out how to proceed
what do you mean how to proceed the
baby's gonna grow a little bit more and
then he's gonna pop out of my wife what
do you mean that's how you proceed with
the pregnancy well no but you're gonna
yeah we'll just figure out just sort of
and then we'll just come to a decision
and no there ain't no decision lady
you're not killing my kid
there is a shocking new report about the
efficacy of these tests in the new york
times
now as you likely have already heard
this friday the supreme court will
convene to hear arguments on the
legality and constitutionality
of the biden administration's vaccine
mandate
that means this week is going to be huge
for the lawsuit that we filed against
the biden administration
we have over 1 million signatures thanks
to you
that is on our do not comply
petition
we need that to increase before friday
help us send our message loud and clear
head on over to dailywire.com do not
comply right now we're counting on you
to help us put a stop to this disgusting
federal overreach we'll be right back
with a lot more
shocking new report out of the new york
times
new york times still does good reporting
some their editorial is awful the way
they frame the stories is terrible the
way they select the stories is terrible
and a lot of the articles themselves
even in the news reporting is really bad
but the reporting itself is often fairly
high quality
headline
when they warn of rare disorders these
prenatal tests are usually wrong
there are a number of tests
that
doctors will give to pregnant women to
determine if their
children are perfect or if they're
defective and if they're defective they
suggest that you abort the baby
how
how often do you think they're wrong
this shocked even me
you'd say okay
they do these tests all the time
gosh could you imagine if five percent
of the time they're wrong five percent
of the time
where
a mother is told oh your baby's gonna
have all these terrible problems you
should just abort the baby and then the
mother aborts the baby and then it
actually it turns out the baby was just
fine and so even by the mother's own
priorities of wanting to have a perfect
baby not a defective baby even even then
she would have kept the baby the baby
was killed when she wouldn't wouldn't
have done that oh my gosh could you
imagine five percent of the time
what if it were 10 of the time
that the tests were wrong
what if it were 15 20 25 30 35 40 45 50.
85 of the time
80
not 85 percent of the time they're right
85 percent of the time
they're wrong
they're only right 15 percent of the
time
five syndromes here
di george syndrome
1p 1p36 deletion
cree duchat syndrome
wolf hirschborn syndrome
crater willie and angelman syndromes
that first one
the chance that the positive test
results are wrong
and that the results say the baby has
this syndrome but actually the baby
doesn't
chances that it's wrong eighty-one
percent
one p-36 deletion 84
wrong false positives
creed duchat syndrome 80
wrong
wolf hirschborn 86 percent wrong praetor
willie into angleman syndromes that that
can cause seizures and the inability to
control food consumption you know really
you should probably abort your baby
right hey hey listen ma'am
you this is going to be really bad
quality of life for you especially but
also the baby's going to be you should
probably abort the baby how often is
that one wrong
93 of the time
it is always wrong to kill your baby
because you consider your baby defective
okay that that is always wrong you
shouldn't do that we all have
imperfections you do too you do even you
you whom everyone loves so
everyone has imperfections so it's
always going to kill your baby even if
your baby has imperfections
but these parents who are who are having
abortions on this information
usually usually the vast majority of
time are not
even killing a baby that they would
consider to be
defective
the lesson here one is don't trust the
science these people are idiots and
they're wrong most of the time and
they're extremely dishonest
so that's the first part
okay but the second part is
justice is a better guide to action than
statistics is
i i have long said on this show that i
think statistics is mostly bunk and you
shouldn't trust it
including maybe these statistics i don't
everyone has their own statistics there
are lies damned lies and statistics
sometimes conservatives push back at me
but one of the reasons for this is
statistics do not a moral argument make
the question is should i kill my kid or
not
should i kill my kid or not and
so
right now if we're going to argue it
from statistics you say well actually
the kid has a
67 chance of having this
problem and this and so and they'll have
a 72 chance of this problem and so i
think his life is only worth a 41 chance
of this and so when you do the
calculation and you pull out your
calculator and you say actually his life
isn't worth saving kill him be
right that would be the statistics
argument that would be the egghead
argument how about the justice argument
regardless of what diseases the baby
might have or that might get later on in
life maybe the baby oh god forbid could
you imagine the baby gets childhood
leukemia that's not going to come up on
a test in the womb but it might happen
and that would be that would be tragic
that would be so horrible
or imagine that i don't know the kid he
turns out he grows up he's 25 years old
and he gets some other disease hurry
grow he's 60 years old and he gets some
other disease gets cancer
yeah that would be sad too
right that would be that would be very
sad
should
you
kill your kid because of
a probability that he'll suffer
just don't just don't kill innocent
people that's a much better rule
because because as the new york times is
showing us even when you think you're
making these really sophisticated
calculations well 93 chance he's got
this horrible
often
they're just
totally wrong
just as wrong
as all the eggheads have been if you
haven't learned that the eggheads the
scientists can be wrong over the past
two years
you haven't learned
anything
speaking of health
not public health but private health
lizzo
lizzo is a performer she's a singer and
a dancer
who makes being morbidly obese a big
part of her act and so it's not just
that she's a larger lady and
you know deals with that and that's just
part of her life she makes it
sort of the point of her act and she
encourages it among other people and
they call it body positivity and she
says oh yes you know you should get
really really fat that's really good
that'll be really good for you
so lizzo just posted a new video to
instagram
dancing around in a bathing suit
and you don't need to watch this if you
don't if you don't want to you can close
your eyes it's not uh
yeah not exactly mozart you know not not
the highest sort of but okay it's her
sort of jiggling around and she says i
gained weight i look tf good
g-o-o-d-t i had to look that up good
is a way of emphasizing
the word good because it's got this
emphatic point at the end good
there's no question about how good it i
i am good and then tf refers to the
f
the i look at the f good
uh i'm not going to
be rude or say anything about
how liza looks or
but but
the the philosophical point she's making
is just not true okay
we we are told in our skeptical society
that that
beauty is in the eye of the beholder
there you don't what is what you
consider beautiful
maybe isn't
beautiful according to someone else it's
all just taste and there's no accounting
for taste
beauty it's just like preferences
this is how we ended up with all this
hideous modern architecture and all this
ridiculous modern art and just this ugly
very ugly society all around us this is
why now when you look at billboards when
you're going through times square or
anywhere else the billboards no longer
have hot models on it usually often the
billboards will have officiously ugly
models on it to make a point they're
making a political point which is that
what you this is the new beauty
ugliness is the new beauty
just like when that comedy quote-unquote
comedy special nanette came out with
hannah gadsby
and it was just really sad
and it was she wasn't telling jokes she
was just saying sad things and she said
this is the new comedy
the the new comedy is not comedy it's
it's tragedy but that's comedy now and
ugliness is beauty and up is down and
right is left
and everything and it's all opposite day
and that that is certainly what you see
in political correctness right men are
now women women are now men
and it's all just words words words and
we can define things however we want
because there are no objective standards
that's what the left is saying and the
right has kind of bought into it too
the right has a very skeptical approach
to politics now too and they say well
look who am i to tell you
how to live your life who am i to
legislate morality we shouldn't teach
students what to think only how to think
you know that all that kind of babble is
very skeptical and buys into the same
idea but actually there is beauty
go
to the sistine chapel
and then go to that modern art piece of
a urinal on the floor of a museum
tell me please
try to convince me that one of those
things is not more beautiful than the
other thing
try to convince me you can't
this is also why the live and let live
stuff you do you don't yuck my yum just
do whatever you want just as long as it
doesn't affect me that was never going
to work
it was never going to work because we
are not just individuals none of us is
just an individual we are in community
human beings by their very nature are in
community jordan peterson had a great
quote the other day was going around the
internet i loved this quote he i'm going
to be paraphrasing it but he said
rationality is a community
endeavor
meaning you don't just
form yourself or your thoughts or even
your own reason on your own
you do it in conversation with other
people and you know this from your own
experience when you're alone for a
little too long and you don't talk to
people and you don't interact with
anyone you go a little crazy we all do
we all do
this is why aristotle says man is the
social animal man is the political and
what's politics mean it means the stuff
we all do together
and there are going to be standards and
the standard is either going to be
beauty or it's going to be not beauty
and
we are going to force those standards on
people or we're going to have standards
forced on us what is it is it going to
be the real
goodness truth and beauty or is it going
to be some insane leftist redefinition
toward ugliness and falsehood and what
do you want what society do you want to
live in speaking of standards cnn does
this thing every year where now on new
year's eve
their hosts get hammered on air and i
think it's real i think they actually
are drinking it could just be a fake
sort of performance but i think they
actually are and then they babble and
they get all goofy and they're drunk on
screen and this is supposed to be really
funny and festive so
anderson cooper leads this show and andy
cohen
who is a radio host andy cohen comes on
and he went into an admittedly
satisfying drunken rant about what a
terrible mayor new york mayor bill de
blasio was
let me tell you something
oh please tell us something andy
watching mayor de blasio
oh don't go on a ramp
stop going around tree lap dance
after four years of the crap
as the mayor of new york
the only thing
that democrats and republicans can agree
on
is what a horrible
mayor has been
so
wow
2022 i mean it's a new year because
guess what
i have a feeling
i'm gonna be standing speaking right
here next year and you know what i'm not
gonna be looking at
dancing
as the city
comes apart
totally right so he's completely right
about bill de blasio he's been a
complete disaster
all the democrats i know in new york
almost every single one
which is most of my friends in new york
despise the guy
i think andy cohen at least may have
actually been drunk there because
anderson cooper keeps trying to reel him
in and andy cohen just says no i'm not
going to do that and he goes on this
drunken rant which was
which was enjoyable but generally
i think the cnn drunk thing is just so
stupid this has become a meme in our
culture that now if you want to if you
want to make something really fun
you know if you want to make a form of
entertainment really fun just get the
performers drunk and that's going to
make it better
right there's drunk history oh yes
instead of just talking about history
where they're going to get drunk and
talk about history or the drunk
shakespeare yeah instead of watching
good actors perform great plays well
they're going to just get drunk
and do it isn't that going to be they're
going to impair their skills and
abilities and that'll be better somehow
yes
and you know what we're going to do
we're going to have these
people go on cnn
watching cnn always an unpleasant
experience but they're going to get
drunk and that'll be better it's just so
lazy and unattractive
it it just it reminds me that we're not
a serious society in any way
i'm no i am no teetotaler far from it
let me tell you folks all right i
love
a good drink okay good cigar with a good
drink i love it
all right i've loved it for a very long
time
but i don't like being drunk
this is this is where we've lost all
sense of proportion and we've lost the
idea of the virtue of moderation
drinking is fine
christ's first miracle was turning water
into wine for people who had been
partying for quite a few days
but you need to hold your liquor people
you need to that is a good thing you
think you ever read
how much winston churchill would drink
in a single day he'd wake up he'd start
his day with scotch and soda
he'd move on he'd have champagne he'd
have brandy and a busy drinking all day
winston churchill was almost never seen
in public drunk if ever i'm not sure
that he ever was
that's what we've lost it reminds me of
that chesterton line a lot of chesterton
in today's show where chesterton said
that the modern world is not so awful
because it's so bad it's in many ways so
awful because it's so good we've got a
lot of virtues but they're totally out
of whack and we don't have a sense of
moderation anymore we don't have a sense
of balance
anymore we don't we can't and when you
when you get these things out of wax
when you don't have a balanced society
things start to break down
speaking of standards
did you know that babies are transphobic
i actually did know that babies are
transphobic
but i have had this point reinforced by
libs of tick tock my favorite twitter
account one of my favorite twitter
accounts
and a viral video that's going around
tiktok right now i've talked about the
transphobic baby at work before
um i went in a room with him today and i
had my wig on which i took off now
because it's
like nine o'clock at night um
he didn't cry
and he was like babbling at me
and i had to look at him and like
do you like me now because
we've
had a moment or do you like me now
because i have long hair and look more
feminine because then you're more
transphobic
and then he started to cry so that was
my answer
i
truly do not know if this is satire or
not
i don't know i could see it be 100 being
a joke
and i could 100 see this being real and
i don't know because our society is
completely through the looking glass now
and when you can be kicked out of polite
society for saying that dudes are not
chicks and chicks are not dudes then you
really don't know then then your ability
to discern between satire and reality is
is gone
but let's just take it seriously
this idea that babies are transphobic i
know a lot of conservatives have pushed
back they've said
you're calling babies transphobic
how crazy is that that's insane you
should that's not
that's not right you're saying that
babies are afraid of tr uh yeah of
course they are
because they haven't had their brains
poisoned by leftism yet so of course
they they're not it's not irrational
but yeah babies are afraid of a lot of
things my baby's afraid when i sneeze
okay babies get scared of lots of things
and it's because they're extremely
vulnerable and so
when
dudes dress up like chicks in big crazy
costumes and babies look at that they
say something's not right there
something's a little bit off stranger
danger get me out of here that is
perfectly reasonable and makes sense and
maybe you know the left used to always
say we need to learn from the children
learn from the babies maybe we can learn
from them a little bit and say huh maybe
the baby's right maybe this isn't quite
right
maybe something is a little off here
maybe we need to
fix things
i i am not of the opinion that you know
when we're young we know everything and
then we just get corrupted
by society i don't i don't think that's
true i think that very often
young people have you know all of their
untutored desires and appetites and
emotions and that's the whole point of
education is to kind of tamp that down
and
give yourself some command over your own
liberty
but sometimes babies are more correct
than us okay and when when our minds
become so
poisoned by ideology that they divorce
themselves from reality
maybe we need to look
to the wisdom of the babes
speaking of threats to our
life and to our liberty
i just in case you didn't have enough
things to be afraid of and to freak out
about and to go into panic mode over
the liberal establishment has given us a
new one
this this sounds like a cheap b movie
the new thing to be afraid of is
flurona
it's
oh you
just when you thought it was safe to go
back into the restaurant oh oh no
you go so what is flurona israel records
its first case of of a patient with
covid and the flu at the same time
and uh you know they're fine the
person's fine but uh yeah you got the
flu and coronavirus
and it's kind of hard to tell
the difference because it's all the same
symptoms
really it's all the same symptoms as the
common cold
before you freak out over this before
you run for the hills lock down put on
15 masks take like 27 more jabs
before you do that
recognize perhaps that
if you can't tell the difference between
the deadly novel pandemic that's going
to wipe out humanity
and the common
flu or the common cold
you're probably fine
you're probably going to be you're i
think you're going to make it
that's
i hope i hope we don't get flu rona i
just you know i just got the rona it's
not pleasant
and you know i was i was down for the
count for a couple days kind of tired
but
you know i think you're gonna make it
speaking of death
uh really shocking breaking news story
that i have to get to i'm glad we had
time to get to it today
according to the new york post here's
the new york post headline
betty white's cause of death revealed
betty white beloved
screen icon
died at the age of 99
around christmas and new year and so now
the investigative reporters at the new
york post have uncovered betty white's
cause of death
before i read the article
i i admittedly am no pathologist i'm not
an expert i did not go to medical school
but i am going to wager a guess
that betty white's cause of death
has something to do with being extremely
old
yep that's the way it looks like that's
looks like what it was there was some
question as to whether or not betty
white had just gotten a booster shot for
covid and so that that was kind of going
around the internet and i don't know
maybe she did maybe she didn't but
regardless when a when a
99 year old
dies
i i don't you know she probably didn't
flip her corvette on the pch
i don't it probably wasn't that she did
too many lines of coke off of the
amplifier at the rock concert you know
it people die
i had one friend die of covid a teacher
of mine
he died of covet winn handman wonderful
wonderful teacher
he was 97 he was going to turn 98 in
i think two weeks after he died
very sad it's always said death is a sad
thing
but
it it's okay
it's okay people are gonna die i suspect
that
a lot of the reason that people freaked
out during kovid and allowed bad
political actors to take so many of our
rights and freedoms and way of life is
because we're uncomfortable with death
we're unfamiliar with death we don't
know how to think about it we don't we
just put it out of our minds and then
when it creeps back into our minds we
take drugs to try to numb that feeling
and ignore the fact that we are going to
meet our maker someday and
maybe that means we need to think about
how we're living our lives and how we're
going to prepare for that and what we
think the relationship of our soul to
our body is in our body and our time in
this earth to maybe
a life after this earth and maybe we got
to think about these ultimate questions
or
we can just stay panicked and nervous
and doing a bunch of drugs and keeping
our heads in the sand that's where our
political rulers want us to keep them
anyway i'm michael knowles it's the
michael knowles show see you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boring our technical director is austin
stevens supervising producer mathis
glover production manager pavel vadovsky
editor and associate producer danny
d'amico associate producer justine
turley audio mixer mike coromina and
hair and makeup by cherokee heart
michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright dailywire 2022.
john bickley here daley wire editor in
chief wake up every morning with our
show morning wire on today's episode
prosecutors choose not to press charges
against former new york governor andrew
cuomo prenatal genetic tests are found
to be producing false results at an
alarming rate and prince andrew comes
under fire following the maxwell trial
join us and get the facts first on the
news you need to know with our show
morning wire